and i was like okay you know what i'm
going to do now i'm going to [ __ ] buy
a billboard
in in hollywood i picked one that has
the [ __ ] hollywood sign
prominently behind it right i already
[ __ ] got like in
crazy trouble with the climbing up the
crane yeah
and i'm off probation right
yeah but but i'm off probation i was
like you know what
i was like you know what that
billboard's not cheap you know or
whatever it's eight grand
you know eight thousand bucks for the
month like and then add on top of that
to get me up there and mount me on to it
you know i gotta hire an entire
construction team
two cranes you know i'm [ __ ] this you
know
and i'm yeah maybe i'm gonna get myself
in some [ __ ] trouble maybe it's gonna
you know
but but
i think that uh that this is gonna this
is gonna
they're gonna [ __ ] find out about
this okay so i
i go up on that billboard and and for
the first hour like nobody seems to care
a cop [ __ ] kind of
slows to a roller sticks his cell phone
out [ __ ] snap shots
idea and i'm like dude i just
because that was largely what brought
the whole budget for the special over
300 grand you know
and uh and then i show up on this
citizen app it says man duct taped a
billboard and some some
it's supposed to be like local in your
neighborhood but somehow like 700 000
people have [ __ ]
like uh viewed that like it was a live
stream or something
and um once that happened dude now
there's hundreds of people everywhere
and [ __ ] like cops and fire trucks
and i'm like oh dude i really don't want
the [ __ ] fire department to do this i
kept my construction team there and then
the the guy comes straight to the first
responders he says
hey look we have a whole team we've got
our own cranes we can bring them down
it's completely safe you don't have to
waste your time and they were like oh
well it's the liability that we
we have to take them down you know but
but it did its job though it did its job
because within
48 hours of me coming down off of that
billboard there were
articles online that's all from all over
dude
from vanity fair i had never been
written up
by vanity fair before vanity fair
variety
rolling stone people magazine [ __ ]
buzzfeed
deadline tmz fox cnn
usa today [ __ ] it went on
and on and on it was
probably the most [ __ ] publicity i've
done publicity stunts in the past this
one might have been
that's a big boy there's a big one
there's a [ __ ] big one and i'm just
like those [ __ ] [ __ ]
faces what they could have had you know
what they could have had and now like
now they need to understand that when i
make my
my neck special and and and
again i taped gnarly in january of 2018.
you have all new material oh dude i've
been touring now that now the
material comes with me on the road yeah
now each bit
and there's no there's no more memory
lane on my new tour now it's the bucket
list tour
it's the the [ __ ] bottom of the
barrel stunts that didn't happen for
damn good reasons and i went ahead and
did them anyway
and so it's a hundred percent all new
material
about new [ __ ] i did so i'm not regaling
the past anymore
and uh and and i'll be ready to do that
whenever i picture that when jackass 4
comes out
i'll have my bucket list special ready
to come out i'll have my my new book
ready to come i bet they're gonna be
singing a different tune but
my question for you is it do you want to
go down that lane that's the question
you still wanna you don't wanna think
we know this works right and that's
without the netflix algorithm right
that's without their promotion machine
me
on my own all students like uh yeah
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son